from Fox Sports and si.com Bruce Feldman
how are you Bruce I'm doing great
well latest example Urban Meyer knows
his team better than most right I mean
everyone says let's get JT out after
Oklahoma the loss 200 you and Baker
Mayfield's plant a flag in the middle of
the field maybe they should move on of a
five-star recruit and Urban's like hold
your horses what a performance by JT
Barrett it was and a couple of passes
that were incomplete were actually good
passes that were dropped
I think should being pointed out that
when they struggled against oh you
earlier in the year it was early on in
the process of JT Baron that offense
getting assimilated with new offensive
coordinator Kevin Wilson a new
quarterback coach Ryan day and you saw
some of the plays that they have really
kind of kind of juiced up this this a
lot of State offense were things that
Ryan Day had brought in things that
Kevin Wilson had brought in and you saw
a team quite honestly that just was more
talented a lot of this game I think was
was one on signing days as much as
anything where the gap between Ohio
State's talent on both lines compared to
where Penn State that was pretty evident
and say Quan Barclay and Tracy McSorely
you know eventually it caught up to them
yeah so is there formula now for to beat
Penn State do you think yeah have it
have a great have a great defensive line
that that's so much more talented than
their offensive line you know and as
good as Michigan's front is you know I
think that there were a couple of
wrinkles there and that caught them
off-guard that that Penn State was able
to exploit you know they had the bye
week to set some of that stuff up but
the other thing is as good as Michigan's
defensive front seven is Ohio State's is
even better and I think we saw an
example of that and also quite honestly
you know JT Barrett and is is much
better than what what the Wolverines
have at this point I think that was the
difference and that's what what Penn
State was was dealing with matter well
let's talk about let's talk about Bruce
Feldman of Fox Sports si.com how the
rest of the Big Ten is gonna is going to
shape up start you just mentioned my
alma mater Brandon Peters finally got in
a game and the offense looked completely
different
that was rutgers on the other side of
the other side of the ball hardball with
a wink and a nod towards the media says
there's a 51% chance of him starting
again what do you think here Bruce you
got to ride him out and see what he can
do for you it gives you a little bit
more time obviously to get to get him
some seasoning to get ready for the big
game the offensive line still has to gel
and I think there's you know you see a
very young receiving corps with a you
know kind of a patchwork offensive line
coming together it's just a lot of
moving parts for them
and they've had some growing pains so
you know look I always thought that this
team was a year away from being a real
playoff contender and that's the way it
looks but you know now you're gonna have
Brendan Peters get you know looks like
at least a month here just a really
audition and try and see if he can take
control of this this job before what I
imagined was gonna happen in the spring
where is gonna be him and Dylan
McCaffrey kind of squaring off it gives
him a head start on that well and the
reason one of the reasons why I bring
this up is because Michigan sits there
on Wisconsin's remaining schedule Ohio
State does not neither does Penn State
by the way so what about Wisconsin
sitting there undefeated what do you
think their chances are from here on out
to not only win the big 10 but the
playoffs etc well they don't have much
more to Ferrara we have the Badgers a
few weeks ago they're really good I just
know they were banged up at the
receiving corps the game we had them
against Maryland they only had three
scholarship receivers but Jonathan
Taylor there's their freshman running
back he's a stud and they're really good
on defense they're really well coached
you know I think they'll beat Iowa but
Iowa could could give them a game and
then you look at the rest of the
schedule I mean they have no margin for
error because the schedule is so is so
just mediocre to be honest I mean that's
what you have in the Big Ten West but if
they can go out of there undefeated and
then find a way to knock off you know
who we think will be at this point Ohio
State you know they're gonna get in the
playoffs because Ohio beating Ohio State
at that point you know certainly you
know I think Michigan will probably be a
top 25 team but with their with the
schedule they have left no certainty
that they will so you know this team may
not have any wins over any ranked teams
in the committee's eyes before they get
the Big Ten title game but again
and you know if you're undefeated and
you come out of a conference that has
Penn State and Ohio State in it you're
undefeated I still think there would be
hard to get left out Bruce Feldman
si.com Fox Sports joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show and now after Georgia
destroys Florida which we'll get to in a
second
there is no Alabama on their schedule as
well remaining so that looks to be a
matchup in the big SEC championship game
unless Auburn or South Carolina could do
something Kentucky and Georgia Tech
surprising is there any chance that the
loser of that SEC championship game just
makes it anyway that that won't matter
what do you think yeah I think there is
a chance because if you look at what
Georgia has especially Notre Dame is
playing Notre Dame's steamrolled both
USC and NC State who are top 25 teams
Nord and they went to South Bend and and
beat the Irish that's a really good win
for Georgia you know and at that game if
they can be competitive and they lose
the game I think there's gonna be a lot
of people going you know what this is
one of the four best teams I don't know
how you would take Notre Dame if they go
11 and 1 and Georgia goes 12 and 1 and
Georgia beat them at their place even if
it was only by a point and their losses
to Alabama I don't know how you would
take the Irish over George I think
that's a tough sell I think Notre Dame
schedule probably has you know more good
opponents in it you will see because
they're very good like there's a lot to
be played out but right now Mississippi
State six and two and Georgia beat the
heck out of them so I mean that win it
that win could look you know if
Mississippi State goes not in three
that's another pretty good win for
Georgia so I think there's a chance
especially with you know we don't know
what we're getting the pac-12 looks like
they're they have a good good chance
again shutout and we'll see what happens
with the big 12 is the way this thing
play don't look at the two two good luck
down right so let's hold our horses for
a second what do you think LSU's chances
against Alabama would be this weekend
not very good I mean there are three
touchdown underdog they're really young
they're young on the offensive line
that's not good to go on a Tuscaloosa
and they do have Darius guys close to
100% he is a superstar running back but
I don't know if they're gonna even with
him I don't think the offensive line
starting to true freshman is going to
run it and then there have to lean on
Danny Etling I just don't think Danny
Etling can go into Tuscaloosa and knock
off the tie well I mean if Miami beats
Virginia Tech under the Saturday Night
Lights this week and then what a huge
game at Notre Dame it's been a long long
time since Miami Notre Dame meant so
much how can you keep an undefeated of
hurricanes team out of this mix Bruce at
this point you know they haven't beaten
anybody who's any good and they struggle
the other day with a one-in-eight UNC
team I mean they you know they've kind
of skated by people I think it's you
know what Mark Richt has done there and
that staff you know they're recruiting
well they're building I think it's been
very impressive but let's I think we got
to pump the brakes on any Miami is
backtalk I mean I said this for a while
Miami's back when they win a national
title you know they're not back when
they win you know beat a top 25 opponent
you know they're they have a ways to go
to get to that point you know let's see
if they can they can you know be
Virginia Tech who's good and then when
the ACC title I mean that's the big step
but for all you know Miami's been in the
ACC for now a long time they even got to
the title yeah but I mean if you're
gonna start again we're so far away but
why not let's have fun if you're gonna
start looking at what's in a game that
people would want to watch in a
nationally televised semifinal game and
you know last couple years based on when
these games have been played it been
ratings challenged why wouldn't you want
to put undefeated Miami against
undefeated Georgia and see how that
works if Miami is undefeated that means
they would have Virginia Tech that waits
that game will carry some weight with
the committee and also if they beat
Clemson to get to the title game you
know that is those are good win okay
they just haven't done it to this point
you know they kind of snuck by teams but
if they do they get those two wins hey
then all of a sudden there's gonna be a
lot more chips on the table and people
are gonna start taking notice I mean
they're good on defense they have speed
I think people are still a little
reluctant to see Malik or zero the young
quarterback just how really good he is
okay couple minutes left with Fox Sports
si.com is Bruce Feldman what happened in
Florida what happened there you know I
there was so much tension with Jim
McElwain and his bosses they really got
tired of a lot of things there are a lot
of frustration it came to a head last
week Jim McElwain kind of blindsided
them when he referenced getting death
threats and then
they called this bluff and said that you
know put out a statement and remember
Scott Strickland the the Florida ad who
was an old Sports Information guy so he
knows how things play publicly he put
out a statement that basically said they
were they asked Michael Wayne about it
and he didn't offer any further details
you know from what I heard on Saturday
night there were people in high up at
Florida he said we do not want to have
Jim McElwain in try anymore podiums
representing the University of Florida
at that point it was like how do we get
to a point where we can you know deal
with his buyout and manage this and have
an exit strategy because they were they
were done with him and now they're
moving on my search committee started
the search started today and we'll see
what they can get because it's a really
good job so anyone with Florida roots
is it possible to where they ground on
Mike Shannon's door and say would you
want to come back in college football I
don't I think the timing you know at his
age I'm not sure that's the route they
would want to go look Dan Mullen used to
work you know his old boss is now the
eightieth at at Florida when they were
together at Mississippi State Mullen
used to work at that at UF I could see
them looking at him I could see them
looking at Willie Taggart who's now at
Oregon who's got a lot of connections
around around Florida I could see them
looking at Scott's Ross I also could see
them considering Chip Kelly because Chip
Kelly's kind of a white whale in this
this coaching's you know season season
this winter and now he would have to get
cleared by the Commission the
Commissioner of the SEC Greg Sankey they
would need his blessing but I think
that's something that could be worked
around the Florida it feels very
comfortable with Chip Kelly I mean this
is the most innovative coach that they
would have a chance to get yeah I'm sure
they can work that around 1,000% so last
one does this mean McIlwain 's barbecue
sauce is no longer for sale on that
stadium Bruce yeah ok thanks for dialing
in Bruce always love your insight chatzi
you bet at Bruce Feldman cfb on twitter
for more Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV
the Rich Eisen show app